cher docteur john et je représente un
client aux moyens considérables qui
désirent introduire le saumon ou yémen
cher harriet sherwood talbot
si votre chat qui souhaitent vraiment
gaspiller son argent ou quoi ne s'achète
qu'ils pointent club de foot
oui monsieur le premier ministre j'y
travaille en ce moment je pense avoir
quelque chose qui va vous plaire je veux
un bon scoop sur le moyen-orient un truc
énorme débrouillez-vous groupe de filles
en tournée au moyen-orient et peut-être
projet d'introduction de l'approcher ou
moins au yémen ce site une blague
on a deux millions de pêcheurs en
angleterre 2 millions qui secoue leur
petit cad merveilleux ce projet devient
une priorité
il faudrait capturé dix mille saumon les
transporter jusqu'aux liés même vivant
pour que votre chèque puis c'est sortir
de l'eau et qu'ils s'en amuse jusqu'à la
saison sèche durant laquelle
naturellement ils mourront tous ne me
raccompagner pas je connais chemin
on ne pensait fou c'est ça ce serait un
miracle si ça marchait
si vous ne voulez pas de coeur ils n'ont
le soutiennent à rien il faut avoir
confiance note la faible
[Musique]
je trouve vraiment que ça se passe bien
c'est une idée extraordinaire je ne
parlais pas du projet jeu je crois que
non plus
[Musique]
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser que
cette folle aventure puisse réussir
[Musique]